just staying in the play Oklahoma  defending well young to the window tell  you what got to find their role get  balloting and they could be a strong  team to talk about healthy all it took  was it look there  Sooners third block of the night young  tried to go over the shoulder he finds  manic yet he flushes it Oh train young  Road win in program history and despite  all of that this team hasn't even spoken  about that win since they hold a big 12  is shaping up to be a banner year Vic  nice from beyond here that a lot tonight  back to a lob and manic punches one down  go to riot II he's going to be ready to  go today young answers and the wolf who  comes young again  no-look pass my gusty  [Applause]